I just want to say before you started I
usually don't wear sneakers to press
junket split I heard that you were a big
sneaker fan so I had to do it I
appreciate it out of respect John Walsh
yes I'm John Wall so can you get in your
top 5 sneakers of all time just top 5
sneakers of all time boy oh boy I mean I
think it's probably Jordan 1 I was the
one that got it started I would say any
hurrah cheese which I wear a lot now
because they're comfy for like you know
and Jordan threes I would say let me go
off let me go let me go the original
Reebok pumps okay and then whatever
those sandals that Jesus and Gandhi
rocked perspective was good you know
there you go and Rachel I just want to
say I'm so proud for the crazy expert
crazy ex-girlfriend yes live show how
was that working out like the land
having land pop up on the show oh that
was so cool I mean the Radio City was a
whole it was a it's one of the most
amazing experiences of my life um we've
been trying to get lin on crazx and he's
just you know he's he's so busy and so
he kind of one of the reasons for having
him at Radio City was when we needed to
cast girls for the part women I should
say for the part of Valencia Donnellan
Champlin who played plays Paula on my
show um gave us Lindsay and I we asked
Lynn who are some amazing Latinas you
know and Gabrielle Ruiz was one of the
names he sent over and so anyway
Gabrielle Ruiz said he's you know part
of the reason I'm here and so she
brought him on stage she was amazing I
mean it's um there are very few people
who can walk on stage and immediately
get a standing ovation at Radio City
Music Hall the rest of us we had to work
for it he just want it was lin-manuel
we're in and he walks on stage and you
know Rises with her feet but he's great
I mean Lynn is he's great cuz he's he's
a writer too you know and anytime you're
working with a fellow writer it's just
it's chill I wore um pasties at one
point in the show and he wore pasties
under his shirt so a lot of fun he was a
guest in on
so him and live in knew each other when
Olivia was on TV show house and we
wouldn't go see Hamilton right before it
open in the previews and we had dinner
afterwards and he's like hey remember
when I was doing theater talking about
house you know inside jokes and he was
everyone I would always be you know you
guys would be doing your stuff and I'd
be off on the side you know he's like
yeah you're always okay you guys talk
about the just a recording process
between you guys and and building that
chemistry how was that like we were
never in the same room no I know
I appreciate that look that's that's
that's that's Big Ups to the Oscars and
the award sound makes absolutely no
literally we I mean we knew each other
before I knew a bunch of people you know
we know people in the movie never saw
each other so you know we early on
you're doing all these things just by
yourself then as the process goes
through which was about two years long
then I start to hear things that rachel
says so then you started you know
modulate your performance you know when
you go back and rerecord things and vice
versa and then lo and behold when when
I'm watching the last night I'm like
golly it sounds like we all were feeling
you know wow yeah hey and Rachel can you
just talk about your character and give
a little bit of explanation for her just
just tease a little bit about what she's
like she's really mature and really
evolved she's smart I mean she's a
literal science and math and engineering
genius um and she just is she just wants
to solve the problem like any great mind
especially math mind she's not worried
about ego she doesn't care where the
idea comes from she just needs to solve
she just she just cares about solving
the problem and she does it despite the
fact that she's mathematical in the way
she views problems she's also very
compassionate I'm in very very
empathetic and very patient and she's an
amazing character
whoever said well thank you guys so much
for sitting down with me I loved the
movie I can't wait people to see this
yeah